okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have two
special guests on the channel
uh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you've watched two or more
of my lives and you do not subscribe we
have beef
beef people okay so before i start our
sponsor today is cooking with chris i'm
actually down 12 pounds on his meal plan
it's a custom-made meal plan for you and
he uses foods that you already like
um if you guys want the link to that it
is in the description as you guys know
trying to get in shape on here okay also
all super chats are being donated
towards multiple cameras and more mics
so if you guys send money today i'll
read your super chat and all the money
goes towards the show and just creating
better content for you guys
okay so to start um why don't you guys
say your name your age your relationship
status
and where you're from
[Music]
gotcha and where people can find you
okay
uh my name is michael uh you can call me
wolf um
i'm 26. um from maryland
i'm
single
uh and you can find me laughing
[Applause]
find me uh on instagram it's my only
social uh hey dot wolfie with two wise
where you from
you already said that yeah oh okay cool
marilyn martin um my name is rhys
um i'm 22 i'm single um
uh i'm from london
was that
i forgot oh and you can find me on
instagram at blue therapy blue
therapy
that's it
okay so
today's topic is something that i
learned recently
so i always thought like you know safe
sex was the way to go
you know condoms and condoms only but
i'm finding out the streets are wild
apparently okay and apparently men have
types of girls i'm trying to be youtube
friendly
that they they they rap it for
and types of girls that they don't
so i want to hear it from the guys
i can go for it is
don't i told them the topic beforehand
so don't go first bro i know we live now
though yeah um
yes it's a thing it's very much a thing
can we see how many people
that time they're like what do you like
how do you want how do you want me to
break this down like what's like the
rationale yeah yeah so like what okay so
you meet a girl right
y'all are you're vibing it's going well
sorry carry on sorry okay okay
and she she's down to like you know
yeah do do the d and do the damn thing
um what goes through your head when
you're like
condom or no condom
uh is it is it what she says or do you
do you differentiate
honestly
it depends on a few things uh
some of it first of all it's like how
much of this
wasn't just a process
but uh
even before that
i think some of it is also like
you know
trying to get a quick judge
of this person's character like
i feel like sometimes like
i'm sure it's the same for women like
you can kind of tell
what kind of person you're dealing with
like is this person
chill like are they kind of like are
they always in the mix
are they kind of
are they more laid back
um
sometimes some red flags stand out to
you like while you're talking to the
person or just kind of the vibes they
give off it's kind of like some unspoken
stuff
like what red flags
i want to see i want to see if i like
i want to see which ones i have i'm
excited there's no like exact form okay
i'm just gonna say for me like i'm not
one of those people like
um
in terms of like it's rare for me like
to have like a one night stand type of
thing it's only happened a few times um
usually in these scenarios like
if we're about to have sex like
i've been evaluating you for a little
bit you know what i'm saying like
we've mingled at some occasion or like
i've seen you at other functions or
whatever and just seeing how you act
around other dudes mm-hmm um
and
you know maybe like if i've already
heard about you
that's a red flag
you talking to a girl like you're
already hearing from your brothers like
hey man like just you know be careful
like
i'm going to say
the first red flag you already the
streets will talk like
if you already hear stuff from your bros
hey but hey but that hey actually yeah
yeah go ahead go ahead go ahead yeah
like
it that's that's probably the first
um
second is just kind of like
when you're when you're talking to the
person you know spin game or whatever
how quickly they are to like
you know
be down you know what i'm saying like
remember remember remember what we're
talking about what we were talking about
before when we finished working out yeah
i was like like
this will tell you some [ __ ] just to
just to feed it to you so you you don't
you don't go there for me so like you
gotta
find out for yourself like because
like guys you know how guys like we
already spoke about you know how guys
are like don't just say some [ __ ] just
to
so you don't go there
don't worry they'll try to protect you
uh yeah there are ones that will try to
protect you but then these guys do just
be like hey
nah don't go there but really you're
naturally like in his head he's like i
want to go there but you know like you
ain't going there before me do you think
some guys like sabotage each other
most i think most yeah i think bush also
known as youtube [ __ ] blocking yes yes
yes um
it's very real
uh but it's like it's one of those
things like how do you prove it
you know well because
it always comes down to like the he said
she said and i think men and women both
have like incentive to lie
you know
hustle
like i mean men it looks better if they
hook up with more girls
like other guys but i did i agree with
that yeah so like like some guy some
guys
like will
will lie about that sort of stuff but
then on the other side like girls will
lie too when you say when you say lie
like are they lying about actually the
action they did do like lying about
their body count no like lying and say
they hooked up with a girl who they
didn't oh yeah i knew yeah yeah
just to like say that they did yeah
because like i remember when i was 18 i
was um i was a freshman in college i was
a virgin so i didn't have sex with
anybody
and like i'd find out like someone was
saying that they slept with me and i was
like well i haven't i've never had sex
before so i don't know
like when we would have
but i don't know sometimes guys will say
stuff like that no they definitely will
and it's funny how like you see the
parallels like usually with guys
they'll lie about how many people they
had sex with like they'll gas the number
and then on the opposite side
i found with girls they'll try to
minimize the number yeah yeah yeah
but they're doing it to impress other
guys you know guys girls are doing it to
impress other girls as well and guys
i think girls are a little more honest
with each other than like i think the
wider girls are a lot of guys
i think girls like to girls bro like
like how do i speak like
i think girls are slamming like i think
girls lied to other girls
so
[Music]
even their home like what they got to
laugh
not their girls bro but like
i've see i cool obviously cool girls
yeah girls can meet each other right
in like let's say a party and then all
of a sudden they they might they might
touch the girl's ass and be like oh girl
you got it you got a nice size
and then all of a sudden they're best
friends like how the [ __ ] does that work
like
the reason i'm saying that is because
it's like
you don't know this girl
so that this girl has no loyalty to you
she don't she ain't good she ain't gonna
tell you you ain't gonna tell you [ __ ]
she ain't gonna tell you true people you
know oh you [ __ ] that's true you know
i'm saying it's like i don't know girls
are too quick to be friends like we
ain't quick to be friends like we like
because again i feel like when guys
talk it's just like we actually have to
talk does that make sense i feel like
guys like
girls will be friends and they'll tell
each other stuff like guys will be best
friends and like say like nothing to
each other
or is that a misconception
maybe i don't know me my friends don't
know me my best friend we don't do that
in terms of like
when you say tell each other stuff like
people they're dealing with like on the
side like
it depends on your friend like you know
your friends you know friends who can
keep a secret and you know friends who
run their mouth
like you love them but you know they're
gonna talk like yeah um
yeah but that is true what you said like
i feel like with guys you got to meet
you got to run into a guy like bump
shows with him like at least eight times
before sometimes before you even have a
conversation bro like do you remember
when but those are the best friendships
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying remember when we had to come
like we've been seeing each other right
yeah and just remember when we spoke i
said bro like we we actually had a
genuine conversation that's not you
understand
we had a genuine conversation and we we
spoke about things we both saw that we
didn't like and did like you know what
i'm saying but we didn't we didn't see
each other instantly and like
oh what's good like we didn't do that
we had to we had one training session
had a couple training sessions
maybe we had even had a game
and
after the game we still didn't talk we
hadn't practiced yeah yeah and even
practice we still didn't talk like that
and then those one day we just like i
just came up to you and i was like hey
bro
that's like we started speaking because
and that it was it was it wasn't like it
wasn't forced
it just happened you understand that it
was just a normal conversation i don't
think that [ __ ] happens with girls
don't get twisted i do believe that does
happen with certain girls
but but by majority like yeah the
majority i don't think that happens
anyway back to the back to the topic
yeah actually this is all this is all
crucial stuff
the little dynamic behind it all
right
okay question
let's go say say you don't have the
streets as an option you meet a girl off
an app okay or you know at a bar
something where you don't have mutual
friends
what are like the red flags that you're
like i need to wrap it like immediately
mine mine is definitely
how quick she gets into the sexual talk
how quick she kept keeps on saying oh
you're fine you're fine you
like
when a girl starts complimenting me too
but i don't know like i don't know
because some girls are genuine but like
when a girl starts complimenting me too
much i'm thinking what's your game like
what's your actual like what's what's
happening here why are you complimenting
me so much like i thought
i don't know
i don't know that that's my red flag
it's like why sometimes you know like
especially if it's off my app sometimes
you even know what time it is before you
even meet the person
and then it's just a matter of like all
right how long are we gonna be at this
function before we dip
yeah
yeah do you have any crazy stories
what do you say
i'll let you go
oh yeah you went before right yeah
crazy stories in terms of um i think you
could like put it to your smart guy you
can't
like no names
no names but just like
crazy stories in terms of like females
um
let me think
let me think
um
like what do you mean though like if you
give me something specific oh something
would probably fall
crazy oh there you go just like what's
the quickest of girls ever slept with
you
like
oh boy
like
the first night
the first night you met her yeah
was it off an app or something else i
don't i don't no
no it was like in person okay did you
ever talk to her again no no
did she want to talk to you again yeah
yeah she was like she's a crazy [ __ ] no
no way
no way um oh my gosh have you ever
hooked up with a girl and found out she
was married
whoa no
no i've had i've had that's happened to
guys i've had on my show before
oh they found out like she had a whole
like family
that's so like me like
that um how do i put this um
yeah yeah but like
i already knew
you just didn't care
i didn't care because dave service no
life like
don't you think i'm doing you a favor as
a man like let's say he was a man right
and
you have a girlfriend that's not even
saying your wife and then another guy
has sex with your girlfriend or whatever
i did you a favor right
right like did who a favorite the guy
because he's like because it's like bro
you expose this girl did you tell him
no well then how did you do him a favor
i don't know
but at the same time well
uh that's too much information um
like you do have a favor if you told him
but if he doesn't find out then how did
you do him a favor [ __ ] i don't know
you're just trying to like justify no no
no no no
listen no no no i'm guilty as hell but i
ain't even trying to justify nothing
like i like
how do you explain like it's
firstly uh
the reason why i don't feel bad i am
guilty 100 but the reason why i don't
feel bad is because it's like
bro
like you are going to do this anyway
or the guy down the street
or your neighbor
it was going to happen
because you did it someone said we in
australia now we in london bro
actually i got okay so i have a couple
so have you heard have you guys watched
manosphere content
no um yeah i don't even know okay so i'm
gonna give you so many samuels
it's basically like studying women and
sometimes i listen to like the things
they say to watch out for
and i think they're kind of funny but i
want to see if you guys think there's
any truth to these
tattoos they say girl with tattoos it's
like
like what did they say if a girl has
tattoos each tattoo is like 10 dicks
she's
i don't agree with that tattoos
they say hoop earrings when you say
tattoos though girls with like big hoop
earrings they're like no i get the
tattoos
but when you say tattoos
yeah like do you just mean like any
tattoos because there's certain girls
with tattoos
you know what i'm saying yeah so like
but not necessarily she's had sex with
this and that guy but just like hmm like
other guys must be looking at her the
same way
because yeah um i don't know they just
say they just they really do not like
tattoos in the sector of youtube i agree
with what he said like i love to like
tats are great it's art exactly and
sometimes you see girls and they just
have
some nice tattoos
yeah like enhancers are like god like
good tats can take someone like i'm
sorry to use the rating system that can
make turn a seven to a nine yes yes yes
yes
yes yes yes
speak for yourself i love some tests
like but like
i think the the type of tats like you
said like if she got something like on
on her like tailbone that says daddy's
little
i know i'm saying like i'm gonna know
right there like nah i'm not about it
but you know what i'm saying like
like
you know what ty's nice you know you
know you know when the girls got like um
like she got like chinese writing down
her spine like all the way down oh she
got like a dragon on her back like that
those tails like something intricate
like yeah that yeah yeah those types
yeah no i mean the thing about the
manosphere like
it's such a
i don't know you see a lot of guys like
it's such a big
it draws a lot of attention and so
all these guys are popping up claiming
to be alphas and they have the key to
like you know what they call like red
pill information for guys like how to
wake up and take your manhood back but
it's like you know what i'm saying like
what's their credibility it's just some
guys just be talking [ __ ] well
because in my opinion i think they they
had to have struggled with women because
why else would they get into it
you have to fight like you have to find
the content somehow yeah like some
people you can tell they struggle with
women and they can they can take the
struggle take the crucial information
that they need yeah and give out
knowledge and then there's guys who
take the struggles with women and just
take all the painful stuff and then just
project out on the guys and pretty much
just say f all women i think those are
typically the guys that like women don't
want
so they just get mad because
girls will never want to give them the
time of day yeah you know
it's a weird field it's a weird sector
of youtube i i was when i tell people
what i do i'm like i don't even know how
to describe it like
like the sector of youtube you know do
you know about the stages of women's
like life they go through
do you know about the epiphany phase the
epiphany oh this is fun okay okay okay
okay i love explaining red pill topics
to people that have never heard of it
so they'll say like a girl based on her
age um is gonna look for like different
things
so a girl from
between like 18 say to 26
is gonna look for like the fun guy that
like god have a good time with whatever
but like 27 it depends on the girl but
like 27 28 to 35 they're more like
looking for the calm like the beta guys
like the providers yeah do you have you
found that to be true
like does that does that replicate what
you've seen in the real world or does
that just sound like nonsense
like remember we were talking about like
i was talking about we just spoke about
the woman with a with a with her husband
yeah the married woman you spoke
that happened right
so like
that has to be [ __ ] because
yeah it has to be [ __ ] it has to be
[ __ ] nah nah nah i'm sure no but but
do you know how they they justify that
okay so they call it they call it
genuine like desire
no it's really cringy i know these
topics are really cringy but i actually
agree as a girl then weakness bro
it's called weakness bro
no no no i i actually i kind of agree
with this topic as a girl like because
because there's certain like
uh like
there's certain guys where you have more
of like
you're like more attracted to than
others so basically they'll say like
the the beta guy the provider guy
they'll marry but they really don't want
him they just want someone to have a
family with yeah because i've definitely
seen girls with like guys yeah but
because i've definitely seen girls where
they're like dating a guy but they like
want their ex-boyfriend like i see that
all the time
yeah
no and among like normal girls i've i
don't get that like one time there's a
girl i tell the story i don't get it
either there's another person there
there is a girl i knew in college okay
and she she dated this guy for like a
month
i didn't really get it cause he was like
five seven i'm like you cannot be
tripping over a guy that's five seven i
did not get it and
and he um was that like her toxic
her toxic ex guy that she was still
tripping over though yeah i don't know
they did it for like a month it wasn't
like i don't know i mean i got nothing
to do with it i mean he probably had
swag or something like he i don't know
he was a loser
i didn't get it i did not get it but but
she ends up like
they break up whatever he breaks up with
her she dates a new guy he buys her a
house okay
she yeah he buys her a house she he's
moving her into the house
how quick this is years later
this is this is like freshman year she
met the first guy okay and she kind of
like hook up with him on and off and
this man was like
wilden like yeah and anyway so it was
her like junior maybe senior year she
starts dating a new guy yeah
senior
either is either senior year the year
after senior year
she hooked up with the freshman year guy
in a party like at a party in the
bathroom
like and i and i saw her go in when you
say hooked up like they [ __ ] about it
i don't know what else they were doing
in there
when they say hook up they just mean
like no no no no no but but
but then then her the guy that got her
the house came later to the same party
and i'm telling you this was the most
normal girl you would not guess it like
she oh my god i was shook
no female surprises me anymore do you
want that old thing back
but that's that's what i think of when i
think of like alpha and beta is i think
like she had the genuine desire for like
the first guy and the second guy like
she was like the safe option
and i think she's still with him to this
day i hope they're doing good but
[Music]
i mean i don't even see it as like yeah
i think it's deeper than the alpha beta
thing cause like i hate those words yeah
it's still like it's just like it's like
it's so black and white like oh you're
either alpha beta bro you know what i'm
saying like well it could be a thing
like he emotionally manipulated her for
a long time when she was like vulnerable
and then part of her still like well i
don't think it's alpha or beta i think
it's like it's not about if the guy is
alpha beta it's how does a girl see him
yeah so it's not it's not like is the
guy alpha and every because you're
always going to find a guy that's more
oh like there's always going to be
someone but it's more like like the girl
has to see you as like the best she can
do
and if she sees someone else is the best
she could do she's always going to want
the other guy
ah
wait i don't understand that that don't
make no sense but kyra look at i mean
this is just that's interesting this is
red tell ideas
and because that's that's
no because because no no no because the
reason i got i kind of got into red pill
was um
like it was they called an alpha widow
and that's like the concept that i'm
explaining right now okay was i felt
like in college i was like i feel like
every girl in my friend group there's
like one guy they just can't get over
and and like that girl that's what i
think of when i think of an alpha widow
was that was that her person she lost
her virginity to as well because that
that still couldn't be that's what she
hooked up to
no no he's talking about the first one
because because she she slept with her
freshman year like when she was yeah
that was the first one
that's like an emotional connection so
yeah the guy that i lost my virginity to
made me not have sex for two years i was
like yeah yeah that's what you mean
why because i was sad
wait
explain
why
because i was like
this is kind of embarrassing um no
because
i don't know i was just like obsessed
and so
like i like moved cities and i didn't i
didn't want to like do it anymore
because i was like
they're just like i didn't want to get
hurt again but
you wait we moved cities would you be
away from him yeah because i was like
yeah
that's real though that's mad like what
the [ __ ] did he do
he made you move to a whole city
yeah i swear i moved from chicago to it
wasn't that far it was like two hours
but far enough
it's like chicago to milwaukee
why
why i'm asking you many questions um no
i mean
i don't know i like
what do they call it like one idis when
you think it's like there's only one guy
it'll never be anyone like i don't know
it wasn't it was it was just like i
really didn't have like i'd only had sex
with him so it was like
yeah and that i yeah
he was like when i need to i go to him
is that what it was
like
i mean i wanted to date him like because
i got him a job actually
oh boy you are one
yeah i'm not even one of them because i
think all girls are
like like you said like
if you lose your virginity to a boy
you're down to do anything for that man
no
yeah i know i was i i definitely like
got him
i like pretty good job actually because
my parents know a lot of people so like
it's like pretty easy if i want to like
set someone up with something that's
what you're telling me about
what you told me i don't know you told
me
you gave a guy a job you go got a job
which time
which time how many times
i think he makes like probably 70 80 now
like decent money
it was not like a softball yeah no
because my parents are like like well
off so i know people so if i i would do
that for anyone though like even if it
was just a friend it's just like yeah
like i would do that first
but
um
you're like i want to be her friend
i mean
it's good to know
uh
do i have a lot of friends in a lot of
places no tell me okay tell me the
difference between sexual attention and
relationship attention you guys give
girls
you know that's how i'm quiet just now
no i could have to process that um
sexual attention relationship attention
i didn't have to process it attention in
the bedroom versus attention yes day to
day bro you look at a girl you like [ __ ]
i wanna [ __ ] like let's be real like
there's certain girls you look at you
like i wanna [ __ ] i wife in your doll
wait are you saying when you're in a
relationship how do you
no she's your attention are you saying
like no no i'm saying okay so i'm saying
like a lot of girls i think think
they're hotter than they are
because they get they can sleep with
guys that would never be seen in broad
daylight with them
you could
like i think sometimes girls think
they're like more attractive than they
are
because like they want to carry
themselves like no because like they can
sleep with a certain type of guy but he
would never be seen in like daylight
because of him because of her
what do you mean
whose choice is it to not be seen in
daylight without his okay yeah
okay i know i know exactly yeah yeah
so i'm saying like like tell me the
difference between relationship
attention and sexual attention
[Music]
go ahead
i mean it's i think to me it's simple
it's like
who would you
who do you actually find interesting and
kind of like as a person yeah and then
if that's the case then sex is just a
bonus yeah
um
i mean you can learn that depends what
you want in a relationship but
it does but like
that's how you differentiate
between like you can learn that from
talking to someone pretty
pretty quickly i guess if you're if
you're looking for those kind of signs
like you can talk to someone and just
like
y'all can bounce to different topics
like you find this person interesting
um you think they're cool or whatever
yeah that's those are have you have you
ever let a girl on because you wanted
sex
have i consciously done that no no i
mean anytime it was
i'm someone who's like
i'm pretty
caught i move cautiously like
i kind of constantly am analyzing
someone as i'm talking to them like um
[Music]
and
i'm not really into like
like some people some people give like
pretty bold signs or like make
aggressive moves i'm not super
aggressive like
you know because in that way to me it's
kind of like boring if if [ __ ] is too is
made too plain or too cool you're like
it's it's like too easy you know what
i'm saying don't you think though like
if it's like
because i'm a b-roll i have about when i
was younger though i would never do it
now because it's like if i'm trying to
[ __ ] i'll tell you i'm trying to [ __ ]
you understand but um
like but like girls hear that all the
time though you know what i'm saying
yeah they do like talking about i'm
gonna [ __ ] like it should be implied
like if i'm talking to you there's some
level of sexual attraction yeah yeah of
course yeah
the the thing i was trying to say though
is like
yo the whole you said you said you're
kind of passive so like things kind of
get exciting right yeah cool my thing is
if i'm going to pursue a girl and not
like i don't anyway if i'm going to
pursue a girl
i want everything straight away
i'm trying to say
everything when i say want everything
you don't need to put on your pants and
we can go straight
we're gonna do that but like i'm i'm
gonna be aggressive i'm gonna ask you
these questions i wanna know
and i'm gonna keep it a hundred i'm
gonna keep a buck so
but like
the things that are gonna surprise you
is the thing that might even surprise
her you understand because there's
certain things that
have is there not things that you've
done
and you surprised yourself
like because that that can happen too so
it's like i want everything and then
like if you are ready to go i want to be
with when you say like things that i've
done that surprised myself like ways
i've moved with a girl yes
yes yeah but i would say that
some of it is based off the kind of girl
i'm talking to exactly like once i feel
comfortable
yeah
then sometimes i'll just like you know
you get that confidence to like take a
step forward you know lean in for the
kiss or like you know just something
like things that would normally be like
really nerve-wracking yeah just like
[ __ ] it or just like saying certain
things like
you're not i don't know
what you try to do
i don't even mean anything physical bro
like i mean like just the whole talking
stage like i want to know everything we
speak about everything like because
for me like i feel like did the sex like
that that's just gonna come you're gonna
kiss her eventually if you guys are
really talking that's just that's
natural bro but it's like
once you've been having sex with a girl
like bro what is there to surprise what
can she surprise you with
at the end of the day because i've been
done
a husband exactly yeah you don't know
you don't know
with
100 million thousand trillion percent
yes
100
i don't know
i think if a girl really doesn't
normally do something you would know
like she wouldn't have to say it so i'll
tell you why it's 100
because when she's i don't usually do
like usually when she says that you've
probably met her for the first day or
two days or maybe three
and i don't usually do this but i'm
gonna take off my knickers anyway like
bro
let's be real you i only spoke to you
don't give a [ __ ] about that
but bro let's be real i only spoke to
you for like two three days
and
um
you're doing it you're doing it and
you're saying i don't usually do this
but like the thing is what you're doing
exactly that and what is the connection
that me and you have uh like
like what what what like do we do we
actually vibe because if we vibe i'm i'm
feeling you you're feeling me and then
you say that [ __ ] then i'm like you know
what matter no no no i'll believe you
because it's like
we had
you know when have you ever spoken to a
girl that you both like
vibro like mentally you're there
spiritually intellectually you're there
and you both feel that when she says uh
if but i don't think she's gonna come
out with a line i don't usually do this
to be honest with you after she's gonna
do it but
it happens though even with people that
you think you're vibing with it's like
it's almost like it's like a default
thing for them to say and it goes back
to what we were talking about when like
how guys cap about the high body account
they have yeah and girls tapping about
how low their body kind is when girls do
it it's for guys because they don't want
guys to think that you know their
thoughts
out here in the streets
when in reality
like if you don't tell me
i'm not gonna be like you know maybe i'm
thinking about it but like if you don't
bring it up i'm gonna just decide to not
think about that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying yeah
which kind of ties back into the
ultimate question of the show is like
see i always wonder where condoms were
like but i feel like like i've always
been really honest like i don't lie
about that stuff but then like you guys
will be like oh you have to times it by
three so then i'm like do i divide j i'm
like do i divide it
like
i
j cole had a had a bar in his song
talking about uh
she said she only
she said she only [ __ ] three [ __ ] or
something so you gotta times it by
you gotta add like a certain number i
don't know and i like i love jacob
for the culture what what percent of
girls do you guys wear condoms with
what what percent of girls that you
sleep with you sleep with 10 girls how
many you wear condoms with
like
we can't just go off percentage like we
can't just say 10 girls
who are these things
where do they come from
what's their names what's their
background like
you can't just say 10 girls
like we go out of 10
that's actually like okay bro you can't
you can't just yeah
[Music]
i would
i'm confident in saying that like
because i'm so intentional with who i
sleep with at this stage in my life and
actually for the majority of my life
i can confidently say
like seven out of ten no bro because
what's the context what what's the
what's that like bro like you don't know
like
it depends on each of these you know
what like you know what ninety percent
i'm gonna say ninety percent because
that that
move that ten percent is like the rare
the rare like one-night stand body that
i don't [ __ ] know where i haven't had
a chance
the rest is like once you get to know
someone well enough you get the sense
like oh this girl probably take care of
herself
oh there's a girl not in the mix like
that yeah yeah oh she got hygiene
right now
[Music]
oh he's going i'm breathing i
think i'm breathing
oh this one this one right here
i hate to do this i got a piece over
here go ahead go ahead
are we talking about this this one right
here no no no so right there those are
the comments on the right oh oh oh so
what's me
yeah what's me
you say something about mike oh they
said you're using your micron i think
you're just like i think you're just
like tapping it maybe oh okay what
questions you got from people are there
questions
oh
okay um don't make it too crazy no
[Music]
uh what is the most girls you've juggled
at one time boy
ah [ __ ]
oh no it's not even [ __ ]
when you say juggled mm-hmm like what's
was sleeping with at the same time
one
one like that like
yeah you mean consecutively
are you laughing
why are you laughing because
like this
this all right cool there's been girls
though mm-hmm
well
we've had sex before mm-hmm but like
i've met
another girl
and then my nina's got his head six
before
i work cool with chilling
[Music]
what's your name just give me a name
um anyway i got you okay you can call
her alexa
i got elixir over here so okay you're
gonna have to take a seat um because i'm
dealing with alexa okay because i'm
gonna lie like that's just
like what comes after it comes out my
girls get crazy
are you laughing
[Music]
yeah
yeah what's crazy that's crazy
i don't know
i'm a girl so like we don't think
anything's crazy yeah yeah i guess yeah
you know don't think anything's crazy no
we don't but yeah no they do get crazy
but like i don't
crazy for me is thinking that you
you gotta know where i am
um 24 7 you gotta know what i'm doing
that's that's crazy to me because it's
like this you ain't my mom you ain't
paying none of my bills [ __ ] off like i
intended
what about you what do you think is
crazy for a girl to do like what do you
guys think oh move fast hold on i
thought we're still talking about uh
oh no this show this show always goes
off
before
[Music]
before we get to that i felt they need
to clarify because i was regretting my
yeah
like
in terms of like
that ninety percent number i gave um it
doesn't mean i'd never wear a condom
like obviously like if that's kind of
backtrack do you regret saying that
because i kind of like that that's
that's kind of a wild percentage ninety
percent is kind of why but like
it doesn't mean like i would never wear
kind of like that's the preference [ __ ]
yeah i throw an economy like
but um
like sometimes you just kind of like
like i said like sometimes you just kind
of know
who you can you can do that with i don't
know why i think
you can kind of get vibes like from
people
you know i don't know how this person is
saying or like trouble
like if you die if you know a person's
trouble yeah anyway i just i needed to i
needed to clarify just because i'm not
out here going crazy like
and i barely i don't even i'm gonna be
out here like that
[Music]
no i feel like do you feel like because
as a girl i can kind of tell if a guy is
trouble you know like i just get the
vibe i can just tell and you should if
you yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait what is like what how how yeah
um i think it's kind of how a guy like
carries himself a little bit okay
um
some guys just seem like thirstier than
others
i don't know so so here's the dangerous
one the firsty one of the nonfirst ones
like do who stole all your uh all your
drinks
no
he was thirsty oh my god yeah um
i got issues with that one
you ever get any like closure on that
i'm am i getting my drinks back
that whole night oh i'll set i'll show
you i'll show you exactly what happened
um okay wait
um i'll i'll show you
i said
at the swipe up on the story bruh you
damn near magnum robbed me cause he
stole mine like magnums
like
alcohol alcohol
these are magnums they're like it's
drinks all right oh apparently he's
he's going to reimburse me apparently i
just looked at this message now
maybe we'll be chilling then but i was
like
the audacity
anyway what were you guys talking about
when i was in the bathroom you asked me
when i came back um just so you can get
like
um
crazy vibes yeah crazy vibes oh boy
oh is that what you talking about like
people want to know yeah bro i think i'm
kind of
yeah crazy all a little crazy and i
don't think i don't know i'm like a lot
well i mean that's dude we're all hard
on ourselves you know what i'm saying um
i like you you gotta ask for what i love
bro like what's up
yeah a lot
oh i just fall in love like really fast
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
love
like that's a big guy
he said love
no no no
i don't know i like
i guess
yeah that's a big word like that's a i
don't even yeah that's a big word
that's a very big one right now that's
why i'm crazy i told you that's a really
big one no no but you let yourself it's
easy to fall in love with someone yeah
especially if they're like what you say
i said if you let yourself and the
person's likable it's easy to fall in
love with someone
yeah but but why would you let yourself
why
[Music]
why
i don't know i think like
that is a that's i don't know that's a
bigger question than you actually i
don't think i think it's a simple answer
but so carry on actually i've only been
in love twice maybe i don't fall in love
that much there you go so so that means
you were talking about something
specific specifically
something specific oh i'm talking about
my last relationship i've like i like
jumped into that very fast okay yeah
okay how did that happen
how
i think i like moving in i'm not moving
in but like basically but this is the
craziest thing you've ever done in it
um
no no it was it was basically like
we both were like unemployed
okay so because i like quit my job to
come to england it got canceled so we
were both doing social media full time
so we just were able to spend like a lot
of time together like fast you know like
i think we spent more time together in
the first like two weeks than some
people spend in like three months
because we were just together and it was
during like a huge transition period
well yeah it was because i was like
unemployed it was great i loved not
having a job
and i was like living at home so i like
when i think of crazy i'm like that was
kind of nuts like just like jumping into
that relationship so quick yeah no back
to the question though like
why do you think people just jump into
[ __ ] so quick like
what would you think that is like i
think i'm like i have my opinion on i'm
just asking you guys i'll give my
opinion
in a bit why um
i don't think we're gonna have to wait
bro
nah yeah it's a it's a lot of
subconscious factors in there
sometimes it boils down to simple [ __ ]
like daddy issues
you know [ __ ] that happened in your
childhood
and um
you know
what do you think
i think like it's like
so like you said it could be daddy
issues that's like that's one thing
but then like it could just boil down to
like
what you do and think on a day-to-day
basis
you know what i'm saying like
we could we good
are you pouring them up
move it this way people just don't want
to be alone
no no you can you can face that way but
just if you're gonna just talking to the
mic because when you turn and you're
yeah
some people just don't like being alone
yeah but like bro like you can go and
talk to your friends like you know what
i'm saying
my opinion my opinion is um
what do you think what do you think of
it of a day-to-day basis like what like
have you got a goal for yourself in mind
in in like when you wake up what what is
your your goal
and if you don't
i feel like if you don't have that
then you're going to go look for other
things
you know options distractions that's
interesting because that would actually
make a lot of sense because at the time
like i i really like my season just got
cancelled and i was unemployed there you
go and so like someone like i like this
might get really deep but i think like
some people don't like
a lot of people run from reality bro
like you see all of this like as we see
social media guy might be flexing girl
might be showing her t's but in reality
she might be
a [ __ ]
in reality that guy flexing might be
broke but he just
paid for that
car or whatever he paid for
to look good on instagram so now
everybody else looking at it like [ __ ] i
gotta get my [ __ ] up
and
like they're not really
focusing on what's what's wrong like bro
if you need to get your money up get
your money up don't be buying some dumb
[ __ ]
to to spend your money to look good to
look rich because at the end of the day
you ain't rich and that's really i think
not a lot of people are in reality oh my
gosh that's the one thing so growing up
like in like a wealthy family
i can spot fake money so easy because
it's like kind of the way people talk
and the way they like their mindset
towards money
like it's it's hard to figure that's
interesting tell us no
yeah no it's like
like i don't know why when i talk to
someone i can like tell what
socioeconomic background you probably
are from
okay yeah and
um would you say like not to like pride
but would you say like coming from like
a more like
like upper class like wealthy background
do you feel like you have a better lens
or like a better
way of
picking that out of people you know what
i'm saying like spotting that in people
well i think people
[Music]
can generally like spot their own but i
think like like because this is we're
like i would say new money
so like my parents weren't rich like
they like became rich so we don't have
like like there's some events we go to
and i feel like so out of the loop
because these people have just been like
generation gender does that make sense
like they all know each other and then
there's you guys yeah yeah yeah no like
private banking events these are new
regimes
no no seriously
there's like private banking events we
go to and like everyone's so successful
and they're like a different type of
wealth like my dad would never get
designer clothes we would never my
family's cheap yeah because he remembers
where he came from
yeah but generational wealth like is
different and so those people will have
like the nice designer stuff but you can
tell like what people actually make
enough money to sustain that because
there's a lot of people that fake it and
you can tell just like their mindset on
money because usually it's like crazy
frivolous spending that they just
they're not going to be able to keep up
with i don't give a [ __ ] and because a
lot of there's a lot of millionaires
that live a billionaire lifestyle
and you can tell like that designer [ __ ]
like private flights like that stuff
adds up my family can't even afford that
one-way trip on a on a pj on a private
i'm a private jet is like
minimum 50k
and that's paying for like you're paying
for the jet fuel the service
all that [ __ ] my like my family drove
everywhere my whole life
because it's so wholesome no like we
would do we would drive like we would
drive no we would drive like 16 hours
and do cards because i'd say i have um
nine siblings so they were not about to
pay for all those you know i think um
you guys like
your your parents understood
value yeah does that make sense like
yeah because not on money but like of
life itself like so if you guys you guys
played cards like most people don't even
bros most people don't even speak to
their siblings about playing card
playing cards like most people don't
even like their siblings but you guys
like made the movie of course yeah you
had and bear in mind what you had was a
lot
if
you want to put it away but
i think your family just had um like fam
like values
i use no well and it's also like like i
think tradition is really important in
families like my mom is really big on
like like we have family we do pictures
with santa every year no matter how old
we are yeah not funny
so it'll be like i'm like 25.
say no they like they do they do um
when i do this this means go closer to
your mic
um santa um well they do at the mall you
you guys don't have that we don't oh
yeah yeah we don't you guys yeah i don't
do that here no bro
see that's might be america loves
christmas
like is obsessed with christmas i didn't
y'all don't do that you know you don't
care about about christmas no like it
depends on like london
london is full of like different type of
people so like
some people go to
y'all got african santa and [ __ ]
punjabi
that it's hella multicultural right here
yeah no it's real multicultural we don't
like don't get like everyone's accepted
i feel like maybe so what did like the
holidays look like here then
i'm like this is my sixth week out here
i don't really what do you mean like
holidays like what's holidays to you
like
so holidays for in the u.s that's like
honestly late november that's when
holiday [ __ ] starts late november all
the way through like
early like first week of january that's
oh so you're talking about fireworks
like halloween
um now i'm talking about like purely
christmas oh oh oh um [ __ ]
bro we just live life like we whatever
happens happens we're like we don't
we ain't really too
fussed like that like london people are
just like whatever happens happens type
of thing i feel like that's what london
is we just go through the motions and
then
[ __ ] just happens you know what i'm
saying we don't really it doesn't like
clench it don't get twisted like when
when it comes when it comes towards
christmas
like you will see you will walk around
the street and you will see like
decorations and [ __ ] okay but like like
you know it's coming yeah you know it's
coming but like
like the actual people bro we're just
walking around like it's normal like we
don't care like we're just walking
around we don't care like that like we
ain't some people come to you like merry
christmas you will say merry christmas
back but like
i don't know man at least
that's crazy i didn't think about that
well i don't care that anyway christmas
like christmas in america like absorbs
everything like from the ads to like
people start putting their lights up oh
yeah yeah
yeah my mom oh yeah people do that my
mom like i love you mom but like
you be playing christmas music
free thanksgiving like thanksgiving
hasn't even started yet and it's always
like what's thanksgiving to you what day
this was given
uh november 25th 6th i love
thanksgiving don't have it that's time
of year
yeah it's like 24th or 26th i should
know this but it's just like
somewhere in there
um
question for you guys what is the worst
date you've ever been on you asked me
this before is this from the chat
i'm already going dates like that so
i just told someone this story the other
day
worst date i've ever been on
um
it's kind of unofficial it was like i
was kind of playing a wingman to my
friend
this is when i was in junior college
back in texas
and
my boy jaron from new york
uh we were near like texas tech
campus and he was talking to a girl from
there and
he
you know he made plans to link up with
her
uh
and she was like oh do you have a friend
for my girlfriend
and
he was like
yeah so he hits me up he's like yo let's
go out tonight like i got a girl for you
or something and i was like all right
bet like what does she look like
um i don't know and the important the
the most important question so he sends
me like pictures that clearly she sent
him to send me oh no and you know how
like how you know she said anyway
this is how i know because you ever get
you ever asked a girl like to to send
pics of yourself or something sorry can
you hear me all right you ever asked a
girl to like send pictures yourself yeah
and she's sending pictures that clearly
are like only like her best angles okay
yeah yeah you can't get like a clear
it's never like a straight on
it was like [ __ ] like that yeah okay and
so already i'm like
[Music]
uh like she looked she looked good but
then she didn't i was going back and
forth yeah i was trying to be there for
my boy because the wingman role is
important right
now
y'all play video games hey support
characters are crucial i'm just a poor
character tonight
and
i was like i like playing battlefield
yeah but i was like it's no pressure
like i don't have to do nothing you know
what i'm saying i'm just there to
mingle yeah just mingle yeah bro
um so we go to this club i was like all
right so we go to this club we always go
too i forget the name
uh
we're chilling there for a while then he
hits me up he's like yo the girls are
outside let's go get him
we get him we go outside
and immediately i see the girl that i'm
set up with in my
like
i knew she was like
she was a thicker woman and i don't got
no problem with that like she was cur
like
curvy like i don't mind extra pounds
curvy small
face
like if you pretty and you got curves i
don't mind like if you thick
but she was like the wrong kind of thick
and
this night pissed me off so much i can
say this no problem like she was built
like a melted ice cream cone that's what
she was built like oh i know
and
i looked at my boy i was like come on
bro you set me up and he looked at me
because he knew he [ __ ] up he was like
yeah so
and me and her lock eyes and she's like
you know you're like [ __ ] no i'm like
yeah oh my gosh i had to wing woman for
someone
oh y'all do that too yeah i didn't yeah
actually yeah they do yeah they do they
do oh my gosh you know i actually i have
set people up so because i've always
been like you know i have this show
right now people meet through the show
like like all the time right but outside
of that i've just always been the person
that like knows people because i'm
always like throwing stuff or like yeah
i just i just always been my part like
yeah
yeah yeah um
so this um
yeah no the other
i can't tell never mind
yeah i thought so i thought
there's about to be someone me and him
doing it
they wanted the vibe it's about them so
you're i'm really supporting you
you're
you're a good friend
you did what you had to do
[Music]
so
they immediately dip he goes with his
girl
i guess they made playing he was about
to smash that night
oh so they dipped off it was grinding
dancing yeah the girl grabs my hand the
girl i'm supposed to go with just grabs
me by the hand and is like
let's get some drinks i'm like [ __ ] i'm
gonna need something to get through
tonight so
we go to the bar
she's like what do you like to drink i'm
like i don't know honey and coke i was
like honey and coke
and then she goes uh
okay great go to the bartender let me
get six henny and coke [ __ ] she knew she
was ugly
so
you know he goes against the drinks i'm
like i'm looking at her she's like i got
it pulls out the card
um i'm like all right she's trying to
get me [ __ ] up so
so she get the drinks we get the drinks
she's not even trying to like go in the
general population she's like let's go
out back to like this little patio area
where no one is so we're sitting there
she's like sitting next to me trying to
talk i'm like mentally like gone i'm
trying to like not
talk to her but not be a dick at the
same time
and
she's like oh drink your drink and
you know i crushed too quick
um and then we're just kind of like kind
of having a surface level combo
um
and i was like ah thanks for the drinks
um and you know
i don't know if anyone here is from
london the us
the drinking age legal drinking age is
21. i was like 20 at the time so i was
like oh thanks for the drinks like
you know i couldn't have got it because
they knew i was underage so they put a
big x on my hand so i couldn't get
drinks so i'm like i got this x on my
hand and she's like
oh we got to get rid of that takes my
hand
no way licks it no way i need no hair
raised my hand like it was so gross okay
number one you use a ponytail and water
okay it's like wait what
what happened there yeah yeah if you get
the x off you use a ponytail like if you
put your like that's how you we would
get him off wait wait
i know i'm saying like she she didn't
have to lie
look she licks my she licks my hand
like trying to be sexy like staring me
in the eyes oh no and then my hand's
just like wet now yeah i'm just like
i was so like stuck so i'm just sitting
here in my hand like it's like a dog
just it just looked good
i was like is this happening and then
she's like wiping it off
right there i was like i gotta get out
of here
she he's trying to talk to me and then
i'm just like
sorry excuse me
all of a sudden i was just like you know
what this is a mistake
she's like what
and her eye kind of twitched for a
second i was like oh she's crazy she was
like what
i said this is a mistake
i shouldn't have come here i said i
gotta go
i stood up and she was like no way come
back like no please
oh my god
[Applause]
and i started walking back into the club
to find my bro she's like following me
like no come on come back like you
didn't even finish your drinks like
trying to get me more [ __ ] up she was
probably going to spike i was scared bro
and she's like no like we can like no
like just come with me like we can have
a good time
i find my brows like brother saying it i
can't do this
he's like come on bro like just give me
like i was like no no like yeah you set
me up bro
i didn't give a [ __ ] at that point like
i've been through so much
uh so he ends up you know his girl ends
up having to leave i guess i ruined his
night i don't know [ __ ] it damn right
you didn't you're a terrible wingman no
like she was harassing me and then she
kept me
she kept following me i turned around i
was like stop following me like you're
making this weird like you're begging go
away
and i felt mean oh my yes i can't even
imagine having to beg for that
and then as it goes
you can get that so easy oh my god they
left
and we me and him stayed at the club and
i was like bro like please like you
secured it right and he was like yeah
i'm good like you know he's still gonna
get hit
so i'm just trying to have a good time
my phone starts blowing up
and she's texting me how's she getting
her number bro
probably him
doing anything to get his cheeks so
so she's blowing my phone up
oh just come to the car
baby please come to the car i can baby
pretty much saying like pretty much
saying like she she's trying to smash in
the car like all this stuff i'm like
did you go though
come on don't play with me
i have self-respect like you had like
six drinks i was just wondering no she
got sick
i drink i didn't talk to you that's the
thing i drank two real quick because i
was kind of like
you know maybe this will make the night
go smoother but then i realized she
wasn't drinking anything she was really
trying to get me faded yeah and that's
when i felt
you know what i felt like
i was like this must be what women feel
like
guys kind of like
i don't like to go i felt like the [ __ ]
it was scary i felt violated oh my god
especially when she licked my hand when
she looked my hand i knew it was over
i've oh my gosh the worst is when you
tell like i know when he gets mad that
is like wait what happened i'm gonna
know because sometimes you tell me you
tell me you tell guys no and they like
get angry i'm like i'm not a hooker
you gotta told me it was it was a g
or gabby i don't know but one of you
told me like some guy like you said to
know some guy and he started getting mad
and started throwing some [ __ ]
oh no that wasn't me you know the
instance i'm thinking of is like i told
this guy no and then he was like he's
like well you're such a [ __ ] i can't
believe you won't be like i don't
understand because and i was like i
don't get it wait somebody said they
said if a guy did that to a girl bought
her a heap of drinks
tried to get her drunk and licked her it
would be group yes that's what i'm
saying yes bro of course i didn't and
this is my i was 20 like i wasn't you
that's never happened to me before i was
she
she was older than you old enough to buy
drinks [ __ ] so like you you she was
scared you were sexually sexually
harassed bro
how did you feel
like i do have a story but like it's now
you said this i do have a story but like
it's
it's not a date
it's not a date because i felt like that
before a way or a girl was just trying
to do yeah but it wasn't a date so um
i worked tonight
so i've known this girl
and i worked in a
a place i can't not kind of say that
but i was in a place i worked in a bar
right okay
she knew how i looked all right
and um obviously when you if you work in
a bar like you go like you gotta talk to
people you gotta mingle why are you
making your drinks and whatnot
um
this girl came to the bar every night
every
night not every like every weekend sorry
every weekend she's she had a book
and for me it's just like what the [ __ ]
is this girl doing tonight bro and you
know like you know when you're about to
click
no
wait
like she wasn't ugly but she wasn't
great yeah
cool so like she hey she
there was this one girl that came to the
bar she started talking to me she
stopped following me what not
and i can just see this girl in the
corner of my eye
just like waiting for you to notice her
nah yeah bro
in my head i'm thinking bro what the
[ __ ] like i'm at work and you're only
coming here with your friends at that
too
like this is harassment let's think
about it this is harassment like you're
only here because i'm here if i wasn't
here you wouldn't be in this bar
understand like you wouldn't be here if
i wasn't here so she like she kept on
coming
and like i even messaged i was like bro
like you gotta stop coming
to where i work like this is where she
found your socials too bro no i i had a
social before oh girl
how did you get how did you get herself
you might have set yourself up for this
no no no no no no no no no
did you tell her where you were no no no
no no no wait wait what happened
um all right cool
you see when i met her i was with my
colleagues right right
i was in my i was with my bar manager my
batman was cool shout out stevie if you
ever watch this um
i was in my bar manager and um
my my my best friend is in france now yo
where is memphis cool
like she and her friend when we first
first met them she and her friend were
trying
yeah when we first met them
like that that's how she got man that's
how she got my um
my my instagram and everything like
i met her she kind of pulled up on
youtube no no i put up on her uh i put
up on her like she like i spoke to her
damn
i spoke to her and then um
cool got her number on what not cool
whatever spoke to her a little bit
um may have done a little bit more than
speak
oh so you'd hooked up with her and then
she just kept following you basically
yeah
a little bit more than speak
oh so you you just
you just like got it like that huh you
just like got it like what like that
like what are we talking about here
you just got that swag
hey point is she she like she came back
and um
like
cool those are cool there's one time
matt like
a woman
came to pick me up from work all right
me and this woman no sexual stuff like
this is like this is my my mom's friend
you understand like this is my mother's
my
[Music]
no like the woman that picked me up was
my mother's friend oh god you understand
and
there was no obviously there's nothing
it's just my mum's friend do you
understand cool
now
my mom's friend was like why is this
girl looking at me like like we got to
closing time on my manager my manager
knows like i can't stand this girl
because she's that she's been here like
five weeks in a row
yeah and my manager was talking about
uh like let her stay let her stay but
he's only trying to let her stay because
he wants to [ __ ] one of her friends yeah
and i was like bro [ __ ] that like i
don't care like but bear in mind like my
manager but like we cool at the same
time bro [ __ ] that like i ain't trying
to
tell them get out of the show that
didn't happen
all right cool now um
um
so she's like she's asked for the toilet
my mom's friends asked for the toilet
i've pointed out in the direction of the
toilet and she's just watching my
mother's friend yeah she's just like
hawkeye yeah like she was jealous yeah
bro
what are you jealous of like
how old is she
the mom's your mom's friend she's not my
mom's age like like
four years old
damn oh ew
girl like your age no no she owed them
to me she's just like bro
i can't say too much
um
i mean she 30s that's cool you know what
i'm saying you're legal you're literally
right
with that no she wanted you she's like
27 28. oh that's true
cool like now she's like she's bro she's
looking at me like
oh like who's this [ __ ] yeah but like
bear in mind like by the way this whole
time no words are exchanged
no words
but she like she's just looking oh like
she's been pulling up for five weeks not
even talking to you no no no no i'm
talking about this specific night oh
this night no words yeah you told me
that i know what and so she's just she's
watching me and i'm like in my head i'm
like bro this is awkward bro this is
very very awkward i'm just trying to go
home so i like
when i tell you that's the quickest i've
ever closed the shop damn yeah that's
the quickest i was like yo we gotta
close the coffee machine we go we gotta
clean the um the the bottles we like
i've done everything so quick and then
when we when we're leaving now
um
this ain't too much of a like funny
story but when we're leaving now
like
me and mum's friends walked out the shop
but she she was like talking to my
manager not my bar manager but my
manager
i know we've left the shop and when me
and my mom's friend are like walking
towards the car yeah
she's looking at me like
what are you just gonna leave and not
saying that and type of thing you're
just gonna leave and not say nothing in
my head i'm thinking like bro like who
the [ __ ] are you
are you like
well i already asked that bear in mind
like i told you you've been on weird
vibes the whole time yeah bro yeah bro
bear in mind i told her the truth i was
like bro this we ain't about to
be here all the time this is this is the
mom
huh this is the mom's friend or is this
the 27 year old this is the girl this is
the 27 year old she's looking at me like
okay
like like like i owe her something in my
bro like like you see when i get into
any type of thing like that like any
like any girl you're gonna address it
like huh are you gonna address it
i will address it but i'll tell you the
truth like if i if
me and if me and the girl is [ __ ] in
that bro i'll tell her like bro like i'm
trying to [ __ ]
shanice
this is over like
i'll tell her bro because it's like what
am i lying for like
then you drop names too huh you be
dropping names no that's not a real name
like i just said i just said shanice but
um
yeah she needs my bro
this story brings up a question that
that
that kind of bothers me yeah yeah how do
you feel about this i i have this theory
like
it doesn't apply to all women
i'm just gonna say that for anyone in
the comments who can get mad but i feel
like women
like when it comes to shooting their
shot like that situation could have been
avoided she could have pulled up at the
bar you know oh sorry
you don't have to be that close just
like within that
a fist you could have you could have
pulled she could have pulled up at the
bar
been a regular patron like chatted with
you on some regular [ __ ] nope
you would have got the message obviously
that she liked you and it would but it
wouldn't have been weird
but like i had this
why do women feel like like their i feel
like their version of shooting their
shot is just like
taking me now
not even that like just being in your
line of sight like making sure you see
them
and like that's supposed to be enough
to like
to get you to like for you because you
always have a guy that makes the first
you know what you know what do you know
how i feel do you know how i feel and
tell me if i'm like
correct me if i'm wrong yeah i don't
believe you do this because you're not
as a person but correct me if i'm wrong
um
girls feel entitled
yeah and correct me if i'm not on this
what i'm about to say
this has happened
so many times to me have you ever got
off like a train or like public
transport or bus whatever it may be
and a girl just walks in front of you
like she owns the [ __ ]
like like like like like you shouldn't
get on the bus before her or the train
before whatever it may be like because
obviously i'm driving on like
she's gotta be in front of you she gotta
do what she gotta do before you go do it
you know i'm just like because i
experienced that a lot like a lot of
females like even when i'm walking down
the street bro yeah for sure like the
thing is i'm so used to that because
i've been taught like
let women go first oh [ __ ] that bro you
know what do you think you are like what
do you mean
when a woman doesn't hold a door for you
i don't
the other day on campus no no this is
crazy this happened to me the other day
on campus yeah
i always hold the door for someone guys
ain't girls if someone's like right
behind me and you know of course
sometimes i feel like dang it you're
right behind me maybe i beat them to the
spot type [ __ ] like
i'll hold the door for you yeah yeah you
go
this girl the other day was walking in
front of me into the east building yeah
she sees me behind her she turns around
looks at me me and her locked eyes
she opens the door
and just like lets it close
on me
and i'm i'm talking about like i'm maybe
like
two and a half steps behind her
and like
yeah it was crazy like she looks at me
and she's coming some girls i'm like
i got something else i don't understand
like did your parents not raise you with
basically manners and like that kind of
polite i tried to jog and like catch the
door and i was like i missed it
oh my gosh no actually
in the sector of youtube i'm in yeah
like i feel like a dude sometimes
because i like
your thoughts are so radical no no like
i put it like okay
i used to watch these guys interact with
girls and i would think they're kind of
rude you know what i mean i'm like why
are they being so rude to these girls
until i started running shows like this
and talking to girls about stuff
and i'm like girls shut the [ __ ] up oh
my god they'll talk about the same thing
they're so flaky like i try to get girls
to come on the show and like there's so
much i can't get them to say yes or no
if the guys are way more consistent
about if they're going to come or not
and sometimes i just feel like a dude
i'm like like i feel like
like
wait are you saying
[Music]
i'm not the best good looking but i got
skills and i got money like what's that
got to do with anything i'm so sorry i
shouldn't
[Music]
are you saying that flakiness is part of
like
females yeah oh my god women are so
flaky it drives me
the fine
like you never you never know if they're
coming or they're not coming or what
they're doing like like that's why i say
sometimes i feel like a dude since doing
this show because because one i'm trying
to a recruit like attractive girls to
come on the show so like one i'm like
okay you're hot come on like
because because like i want to make
money right yeah but like i just noticed
if a guy says he's coming like most of
the time he comes a girl it's like 50
50. like i never know if they're coming
or not sorry guys what she got what plan
she got someone buying her dinner no bro
it's not even that bro like if she's hot
if well no it's just girls are flaky
in my experience with just getting them
off the show i'm not gonna lie like even
like bro
i think girls don't give a [ __ ] about
our time but they care about their time
more yeah you know yeah
i don't give a don't care bro like i
don't care what we got to do you say bro
you waiting for me i don't go [ __ ] what
you're doing
that don't think like whatever they're
doing is um more important
but how do you feel about
how do you feel about that like all
right that one question just about
girls shooting their shot like
every once in a while like i love when a
girl like comes up because sometimes i
don't notice you sometimes i don't
notice there's a lot of hands on like i
see
i don't notice you and like my my last
boyfriend i shot my shot at him so right
yeah oh how'd it go
uh it's a uni so he was he surprised
well it was
um no he he was a big like tick tocker
and i saw he lived by me yeah so i made
like a
a video about how i wanted to hang out
with him and then like yeah and then he
saw it i mean then we started dating
like two weeks later
so it was okay that's different i feel
like
yeah that's what i i if he if he
rejected me i would have taken that [ __ ]
down like what if like
we're talking about like on on the
street like oh oh
on the street just in general like say
like this
classic scenario like you in the club
you see a guy you all keep making eye
contact like y'all coming i don't know i
don't go to clubs it's just like a
battle between who's gonna
my experience if you don't approach the
girl that's it like yeah bro
because we give you guys the eyes
let me give you guys the most obvious
eyes okay if i if we make eye contact
and i go like
and i and i give you the eyes i i feel
like you guys should know i feel like
you should what is
it's like
go ahead go ahead it's it's just yeah
i'm ready let me look at that yeah go
ahead i want to see this all right who
should i get who should i i don't know
you you're looking at the camera camera
no i can't do that
pretend the camera is like it's like we
look up and we look down
[Music]
yeah if i did that to you you wouldn't
know
you know like no we know every time so
it's like so then why don't you approach
it
because it's better then it's like
what are we gonna say like then we gotta
then we gotta formulate
because honestly like the first words
you say to a girl crucial yeah
especially especially if she's bad
if she's bad you can't just say anything
you can't just be like to be honest
dang i noticed
like you can't say some [ __ ] she heard
her
what's your opinion
what would you guys openers be
on the back like with a baddie like with
me what the [ __ ] with you
i'm the baddie
you can't handle that you're like what
the [ __ ]
we've been chilling now like you're cool
i feel like i can say this this is the
hype oh my god
what's your opener what's your opener
both of you oh yeah
i listen if you ever heard this line i'm
sorry
[Music]
i like
i go like this and it depends on the
scenario because i i
i'm like i speak to girls when i'm at
work like that's the most times i speak
to girls like when i'm on the street
doing do what i need to do with the bar
that's the perfect place no no i don't
work there no more but like oh you know
oh you do massage yeah no no no no no
no
no no no no no no listen listen wait
listen
i do not do that because
we stay professional here my clients are
only clients cool
i need to get that out of the way you
just almost [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
cool
um
i do security by the way yeah um cool
like
i got two questions this is this is this
is the pickup line this is pokemon
um i say something about
like
for me like i like when girls got shoes
got nice shoes on i got two questions
where'd you get them shoes from because
i like them
and then the second one is
what's your name from there
i'm speaking like i just speak or
or i got a second i got a second one
excuse me have you got the time she
pulls out her phone i'm like [ __ ] since
your phone's out you might as well
give me your number as well
those are good actually that's my lines
though
what are your lines i wrote a couple
lines
that's what i'm saying like when you
just y'all can't just get that look and
then expect like
it depends on the girl like once you get
that look
i'm trying to come up with my mind like
dang what can i say
you talking about if you get a look yeah
yeah just in general if i get the look
i'm not playing
pressure bro like
i see like i'm because most people like
let's let's be honest like if a girl
gives you the look and you go up to and
talk to her usually guys act like she
didn't just give you the look they were
like oh so what's your name did it like
i don't do that it's like i see you
looking at me and i was looking at you
too so what's good like yeah you gotta
put them on the spot like that's what i
would do
i look like i'm first of all i'm not
you're smooth
yeah but that's like it's like changing
like like he turned the tables yeah
yeah yeah i'm like that's decent
actually
yeah y'all get that optical pressure you
get the real pressure but no first of
all i'm not pulling up unless you give
me the visual cue like once y'all give
the little hey like you know what i'm
saying like then i'm pulling up
but it's more just like
i'm random
i'd be nervous and [ __ ] so as i'm coming
up
i'm coming up with like as i'm walking
towards you i'm coming up with some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah real quick yeah it's
hit or miss
and
normally i'm gonna go with something
funny
or normally i'm gonna go it depends what
she's doing is she vibing chilling by
herself it's like
like dang why you by yourself like
that's crazy yeah you know i don't know
something like depends what i'm on as
well yeah you know i'm making some
light-skinned faces i'm making my voice
deeper than it probably is
you got out
you know what i i skate yeah i skate so
i'm on my sometimes i'm on my skates and
i see a baddie yeah i see a bad one so
i'm like oh you pull up under the skate
skateboard on my roller skates bro i'm
like before the night
yeah playing with rollerblades in line
no no i'm not rollerblades
is that the four yeah yeah so i'm not
like imagine you're so like imagine like
cool dude i'm gonna put like this so
she's because the camera can't see this
she's over there right
i'm behind her but i've already done
seen her face yeah
cool i'll go there because i can skate
backwards
i'll go there and just skate backwards
and just start talking to her yeah yeah
bro hey if y'all ain't never seen roller
skaters escape backwards that [ __ ] is
the smoothest [ __ ] yeah bro
hey what's your name uh he's he's trying
to get like you
no for real
that's a roll bounce [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is so cool
especially with like you bro you're an
athlete bro come on now okay we got a
super chat um you never see me scare
bust my ass
okay okay we got a super chat guys thank
you for the 3000 crc from ryan connie i
don't know it's crcr but thank you
um mary won a single parent but child
will always hate you or a chronically
obese person that will never lose the
weight
so you have to pick a [ __ ]
let's call pick it like a little call
this game pick a [ __ ] so like pick one
and so one girl is overweight she'll
never lose the weight the other girl is
a single mom
then the kid hates you and will always
hate you
oh i'm gonna go single mom what really
i'm gonna [ __ ] about that kid
there's no rule that says no no this is
saying like i'm not saying i'm not gonna
try
because no no we're assuming assuming
we're going into this without knowing
that the kid's gonna hate you it's not a
prerequisite right yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] about it again
[Applause]
like i'm gonna try if i love the mom
if i really if i really [ __ ] with the
mom i'm gonna make an effort with the
kids yeah of course but at some point
kids kids can be [ __ ] yeah
they're gonna be happy again i ain't
gonna force would you would you date a
single mom
i already have i've done that before
really oh why what was your thought
process
i don't think you should you're young i
probably shouldn't have yeah what you
doing
uh
she was as bad as [ __ ]
we met on tinder and that's exactly why
she was pregnant
but i mean
she single first of all young single she
was young too she was younger than me at
the time younger
worse in terms of like decision making
like yeah i mean responsibility i was
like
24 she was like 22
okay and
i don't know
young single moms
they'd be trying to get it in
like they're trying to find a step daddy
no but not even that like i'm just just
young single moms [ __ ] oh i guess
probably all single moms
but i think the young ones they're not
necessarily trying to find a step daddy
they still trying to be hot girls you
know what i'm saying
and
the one i was talking about she was cool
but she was on some hot girls too wait
so what about what about you i'm taking
the fat girl bro [ __ ] the kid you're
taking the fact
i'll tell you why because like like cool
me and that girl we're gonna make we're
gonna make a connection yeah oh wait
this is you said mary
you're with them for life you pick a
[ __ ]
like i don't know
i'm not living
right yeah bro i'm not living my life
without like with a kid that's going to
hate me forever bro do you know how much
mental headache that is bro yeah i want
to live my life smoothly bro i wanna
just i wanna not man
no i'm sorry ryan is that his name yeah
i'm going with the fat girl because she
can change yeah i'm gonna put her on the
work no no the whole point is she can't
the kid's always going to hate you and
she's always going to be fat you know
but even if she's always going to be
[ __ ] because she always going to be
fast wait how come that bro oh yeah
that's it i don't know that it bothers
you
if it bothers me we wouldn't be scared
in so then you pick the single mom
no
[Music]
because
give me one make me pick
[Music]
what
oh
okay
all right i'll give her one you give her
one yeah okay okay give me one
ufs
all right
you gotta marry a guy
that
[Music]
nuts in 30 seconds
every time okay and then he's done
okay great guy though great guy but he
nuts in 30 seconds every time and that's
it okay one round
one round knockout
okay who's guy number two all right cool
guy number two thank god though great
everything else everything else got
money
[Music]
personality
everything that's it
the dick in there bro
and he'll never get better
we know there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there like that
but
um
he got good dick
okay
yeah okay
okay you got a real good dick
[Music]
but
like bear in mind like he let's say
let's say um we're gonna get a little
bit explicit but let's say like you're
not a girl that i don't know
but let's say you're not you're not a
girl that's um squats
yo he's making you do that every time
okay
like
okay okay okay
like he does his job okay
but i know i had no input
okay
i said i
[Music]
he's got a good dick okay but i get that
he has
ambition ambition in his head
but he's a bum at the same time he don't
he talks about making this money or
making that move or being the next like
most people okay
[Music]
it's like bad sex basically but like the
worst sex imaginable
[Music]
this is the way i would think about it
okay because again when you start a
family it's not about you
anymore that's true so i would think
like i'd rather have i don't want my
kids to be raised by a bum i get that
like what i'm saying when you when you
make that decision to have a family
mm-hmm
that's
you know you gotta be state for until
death do us part now
i mean it would be like
i'd maybe buy a vibrator or something
oh that's true though most like i've
heard a bunch of stories about girls
like he can't [ __ ] but like he's a good
guy so i'ma just
i'm saying yeah or they work out a
scenario where they can do their thing
on the side
no that's not good for kids well it's
not they don't gotta know about it i
don't i think that [ __ ] i think i like
[ __ ] usually mom's mom's had her soul
cycle class i said before
if she ain't [ __ ] you then she
[ __ ]
the vibrator
yeah but no the vibration okay i'm gonna
do another girl okay i'm gonna do
another one okay okay so
would you rather have a girl that's a oh
eight nine or ten like i'm like model
level pretty okay
but
mother's ain't pretty by the way i don't
think but carry on okay but
she's like not she always needs to know
where you are
whatever other girl you're going to say
no but what other girl is it like i
don't even know or a girl let's let's
put her at a five like just average
looking her
huh
i don't even care like her bro you don't
need to know where the [ __ ] i am 24 7
like no five
bro yeah
bro but sorry carry on sorry but
she's a kid
but she's a really good really good wife
really good so i was a kid because i
know like biologically you guys are
predispositioned to like hate other
people's kids
yeah like that's why in the wild the the
males like kill off the other cubs if
they like take on the lioness
like men like biologically like don't
want to give their resources to other
people's kids so it's like it's like a
reminder that they weren't the one to
conquer this woman yeah so it's kind of
like it's kind of like the same way
women are attracted to success and like
height and stuff like that like you guys
can't really get rid of it the way i
can't really get rid of
i don't you know short guys
oh yeah
damn so
guys more than tall guys like the five
five range they it's either five five
like a tree
five five guys
um or i've noticed like like freakishly
tall guys like tall girls
like six seven six six i'm not gonna lie
what about you like i wanna ask you this
question do you like two girls
cause you're the longest [ __ ] bro if
they're attractive
yeah of course yeah like if i'm
attracted i mean of course there's a
limit though there's a limit to how tall
i'll go
um
like if you know
she told me you're a tool guy bro so
well that's the thing i say that but
then there's girls like
what's her face elizabeth cambridge okay
that wnba player you know what i'm
talking about yeah yo she can post me up
hey duncan
most guys don't care there's some guys
that have like a thing for height and
but most guys don't seem to care that
much
yeah like but at the same time i can't
go too short either okay you're five
feet tall i can put you in my pocket
like how's that gonna work how's it
gonna work when it gets to like
i'm just like six nine six oh my god
you're six nine this guy's not realizing
that
um so what's the shortest you date
the shortest i date yeah
and the tallest shortest and tallest
there was a girl on my team she was hot
but she was like six five at my in the
us but she was hot
yeah she's hot she had guys coming at
her too yeah she's married to a 610 guy
now but oh good for her yeah the kid's
gonna be eight foot left yeah
i don't know probably shortest i'll go
and the thing is like i i broken this
rule like i usually say like i'm not
trying to go below like five seven but
i've dated like five five yeah
if they're hot enough you know
yeah you have to like if you attack
someone like this is what it is yeah but
like
it can be kind of awkward especially
like in the bedroom but like once you
get used to each other's bodies like you
know what [ __ ] works and what what's
kind of awkward but
tallest
um
six five is that too tall
you know i say yes but then again i
would rather just okay just assuming
like just in general you don't have to i
know there's gonna be exceptions
in general probably like
six four six five i don't know
i've never but the thing is i haven't
gone that high
but you know they out there
yeah they out there you you love tall
girls right that's like your thing yeah
yeah just something special about them
so yeah like you already know like the
girl that plays
yeah
volleyball team oh she's not involved
i know who you're just talking about
i know her very well
in line
hey but yeah she's just totally [ __ ] but
like in my head i'm like bro you know
what i could do if you're high like
you know what i'm saying nba children
bro no not even
hey my head you see where my head anyway
[Music]
yeah i am i am i am like i am 100
100 million i go live these magnum they
taste like cough syrup
they're good they're good but like it's
like cough syrup
i don't know jamaica i've never had one
he said this is jamaican yes
i think i'm gonna actually end the show
because apparently i'm throwing a party
oh did you mean are they coming
we'll talk about it off camera no wait
wait wait wait wait i think we got a
couple more things we got hey we gotta
give her another like ultimate another
ultimatum okay
all right
this guy is
four foot ten okay
other guy other guys
why are you laughing so hard that's not
funny it's your reaction
okay okay okay okay i look at short guys
like this is body shaming that's crazy
you know i know what i'm saying okay
i look at short guys
like women
like like one time my ex-boyfriend got
mad because i was like joking with this
guy was like five five like it was
before we were dating and i was like oh
we'd be like so funny the world's like
most mismatched couple but i was like
dead kidding i was like i don't even
look at you like at all because i was
like i literally forget
you're like a man
yo
i'm sorry it's just i can't i'm i don't
think you said you're a [ __ ]
little ass boy
and i was like oh trust me you don't
have to be worried about it oh my god
but you ended up dating him no not him
like
my last boyfriend was mad that i like
was like doing that to the guy but i was
like oh i didn't even realize he felt
bad for the guy no like he like he was
very jealous so he was like
so but i was like
him oh no
like damn i just and you said that in
front of him no i didn't say it in front
of the show that would be mean i hope he
doesn't watch this sorry josh
oh she almost said his name
you know your name begins with a grj ah
but i mean i think i think it was all
right bro she didn't even give the guy
okay let me start over since 410 is out
of credit yeah out like him
kids in short i'm like run you gave her
a wolf bro
this man
is wealthy okay financially stable
okay financially literate
but
okay
he's ugly okay
okay ugly like
god damn okay yeah and he's got terrible
b.o okay
and he could cover it up you know if he
showers goes on there's no changing that
it won't ever change there's no change
in that like it's his base level
is he just a trophy
or is he like yeah he can be whatever
and he's going to like i feel like
jackson
and ugly like you could
jacked and ugly but like his base level
bo is atrocious okay bad b.o oh yeah i
can't i like kind of a bad sense of
smell so
oh this will this will okay
okay okay
you're gonna smell this
yeah well i just fight so if you have
you if you don't smell that and be good
okay okay who's the other guy who's the
other guy all right so what did you say
he he's wealthy he's jacked but he's
well he's jack he's ugly as [ __ ] and his
bo he smelled like doo-doo
he can cover it up sometimes but like
it's always going to come back like his
base level will be uh yeah yeah cool so
this guy's wealthy too okay
guy number two is wealthy yeah they both
oh so the rich guys be like like wow
yeah oh
the life you come from though yeah
exactly so
normal
um
this guy's well for you
but oh boy
oh boy
he's breath
[Music]
he's wealthy
he treats you real good okay like he's
hitting all the spots in terms of like
sexually mentally
everything yeah it's just the it's the
background yeah he got bad breath
and
he pulled up on
okay yeah no i and his teeth okay i like
yellow as [ __ ]
is it is his face good though
like is he a good face
yeah yeah he got a good face okay you're
a good face but his teeth are yellow and
[ __ ] doesn't matter
his teeth are yellow as hell
he can't even like every time he talks
you just see his teeth
and like let's he got like polka dots on
his teeth so that he got like black
spots okay
who you going for
who am i going for
uh
probably guy number two because i could
like avoid the mouth area i'd
then i smell it all the time i'd rather
just smell it here than smell it
everywhere
like because then if i'm like i can at
least be like like close your mouth hey
the other guy's ugly too though my guy's
ugly too yeah have you ever like like
like spoken to a girl she's fine as hell
your breath smell like [ __ ]
yes breath yeah breasts
unfortunately boston bro
reminder to brush your tongue
your tongue your tongue scraper your
teeth yes your teeth but your tongue
your tongue because there is one girl
that we know do we know that we know
bro you have to tell me this off camera
yeah i will you know
or what you might have seen or you might
not know about you've seen 100 million
percent
but she's like she's fine she's
furthermore she's even a wife you
understand i think she's a wife my bro
her breath
i can't do it
i can't do it i can't do it like what
are you doing in that situation
you can't do nothing
you can't move forward why don't you
just say something no no no yeah i will
hey baby girl you want to look at it
what hey baby girl you want a mint
that's a terrible way to say it
honestly i feel like that's worse all
right cool well cool this is this is a
question if you love then cool if you
guys got bad breath right
you got a girlfriend
you got a boyfriend
i know you got bad breath
how would you like
some people have chronic bad breath
though like it's like a
but then something like you would think
something's probably wrong then
like chemically
imbalanced no like they're not doing
like something
or something yeah i don't know
yeah so like yeah how would you guys
rather someone tell me like i've had my
girlfriend tell me like when my [ __ ] was
kicking
she's just like oh my god babe like you
know about how would you like to be told
and how would you not like to be told
it's like if it's someone i know like if
it's my girlfriend like my main like we
know each other or my family we know
each other they can tell me they can say
it any kind of way i might get mad but
i'm gonna do something about it but if
it's like someone i'm interested in and
like i want to get to know
yeah i'd appreciate them telling me
but i would hope i would hopefully still
want to talk to me after i faced it you
know what i'm saying okay ah that's good
honestly the scarier part is being the
one to say that to somebody yeah that's
the scariest part telling someone their
[ __ ] no no sometimes i don't care like
sometimes
like i'mma realize that sometimes like
someone's breath will stink
i'll know your breath stick but it's
like in my head like i do a calculation
it's like if my breath stuck would you
tell me nah you don't tell me [ __ ] that
you better go
and talk to timmy with that breath how
was i how would you tell them though
kind of like just like yeah no no for me
like i'm just keep it real with you okay
like
i'll be like yo
that breath stinks man
and that's it
because what else are you gonna say
i feel like there's even a better way to
say it
no no but i mean it was it was someone i
was never like gonna talk to again then
like don't tell them but if i wanted to
keep talking to them i'd probably just
tell them no i'll say your boss thinks
but i like i'll actually say like that
and the reason why is like bro like i
would say
and then laugh
you know
i'm like your brush stinks
too probably and i'm like
away from it
and then i'll be like now like if it's
someone i really like and i want to keep
talking to and i don't want them to
[ __ ] feel insecure
i'd probably just be like
bring them
you know take them to the side
and just kind of be like hey
first of all i'd make sure like it
wasn't just one occasion if you're
smelling on multiple encounters i then
i'll take them aside just be like hey
like um
i hate to be the one to tell you this
um
but just like no like i just noticed
like
i don't know if you need to brush your
tongue or something but oh boy
because i don't want to say the word
stink like that's just i feel like
you would do better if you just said go
brush your teeth
nah like bro like if someone says like
bro think about it someone's like hey
bro i'm not gonna lie like he's gonna
brush your tongue like you have to tell
them that because some people miss
crucial steps in their oral hygiene
routine some people will brush
and they don't floss or they you know
they just rinse with mouthwash but they
don't brush or floss [ __ ] like that i
was like you gotta do all three the
communication part of it is important
yeah
like
how you say it this is stressing me out
how you say is important no like i feel
like that's the wrong point how you say
it not just if you say it or not because
if you say it is one thing if you've got
a boost to say it that's one thing but
that's about how you say it
and then also it's like 50 50. the other
50 is hoping that they'll just take it
as
this person really is trying to help me
yeah not trying to roast me yeah but you
got like i think that's that's a
conversation
right
conversation don't get twisted but
that's a conversation like bro like you
got you kind of got to stop
but okay i gotta i got another question
of two two pick a [ __ ] okay
okay you keep going off camera go a
little seriously
[Music]
um
[ __ ] number one
great girl
okay like
everything everything you look for i
think i'm going for bits number one
but
she slept with
your best friend
it was
like how long ago how long ago no i
don't matter bro
imagine imagine bro you're about to have
a wedding yeah and you know your boy in
his head is thinking hmm yeah bro you
better have fun because i remember that
like nah bro okay but it was it was
let's say let's say you're 33 okay and
it was like three or four years ago it
was a while ago
great girl everything you look for and
he's he's moved on we're 33 now he slept
with her like
yeah a while ago other girl
29
other girl okay hasn't slept with your
friend
and let's say that was she's
the other girl like has only slept with
like five people
other
slept with 40 guys but you don't know
any of them
also great girl also great but what like
which would you prefer
the 40
but do i know do i know she's you don't
you don't know any of them yeah
for you
we know their body count going in yeah
you know second girl bro
yeah
second goal i the reason why i asked how
how
how long ago she slept with the friend
because if it was like when they were
teenagers or like early in college or
something that's a different version of
that girl i actually she might have been
going through her her whole face or
something well i actually like i had a
really hard time if a guy slept with my
friend oh but if it was like a long time
ago then it's like i don't know like i
don't i feel like me like i don't care
sometimes like
oh no no no no no no no yeah anyway
i'm gonna go with the second girl no no
no no yeah
i can't do all of that you can ask me
one more if you want before we end the
show
i'm out of ideas you're out this is too
hard you're good you're good you're good
you're right it's hard to come up with
good like
good options you got you got one yeah or
no oh you got one yeah i mean i gotta
come over maybe you could do two if you
want cool oh you got two all right
cool cool cool watch this
i said watch this um
are you gonna do guy number two or
should i do both of them if you got both
i'll let you do both
both
i'll go one right now but if if i do one
it might like trigger sign in your head
um
number one
guy number one
he's um
your type
okay
yeah
and um
he
yeah he's your type
and
he like this that he's taking all the
boxes okay sexually
mentally
spiritually okay
physically which is obviously sexually
um
and um
but
he's trying to have a threesome
with you
and your best friend okay
yeah that's that's that's god yeah no
yeah cool yeah he's trying to have a
threesome with you and your best friend
bear in mind you like him you like like
him
but in his head he's just like yo yo i'm
trying to
okay but he doesn't disclose that
okay
so you don't know that so specific
what if it was what if it was happening
like she's trying to have a threesome
with her and her best friend regularly
oh oh yeah oh that's a good one let's
say he was trying to have a threesome
with you and your friend regularly
[Music]
but he liked him
he's like and and he he he's husband
material
cut
[Music]
no that'd be the weirdest [ __ ] ever okay
but regularly how about like
twice a year
no
okay
well it's 300 there's no point in me
even giving a second one then yeah no
there is because you can you can give
the same scenario but like he got like
different
attributes
great guy
you're going to do like oh my god cooked
sorry
best friend cooked no no i didn't say
best friend you said you're about you
said you're right you're friends no no
no i also want your friends okay
why would you like i forgot
oh my god
damn i i can't i really can't think of
you awkward you're gonna choose mine
yeah like
to make it
he's hooked up
over his own his ex
and he really likes her and then do you
like getting back into conversation
um but at the same time he's like oh i
really like you he's actually saying
these things to you he's like i really
like you like
but at the same time i'm talking to my
ex and he's telling you these things
are you going for
are there one guy that wants a threesome
yeah like those are my options
guy number one though how does he just
want it once or does he he wants like
continual threesomes
let's say he wants it once i probably
pick one just because
wait uh
yeah i knew this was the exact one is
the x okay it's the x the love of his
life oh that's the love not the love of
his life but the girl he loved
well so he doesn't love her so what up
so what about that it's not like he
don't like you
but he loves so what if i gave him an
ultimatum and i said look like if you
want to talk to him like what would he
do pick the x
[ __ ] i don't know
that's at first i'd probably do i'd be
like
if it got that serious no no no no no i
just say mine
uh okay okay mine is just mine was kind
of simple i was just gonna say this
guy's super emotionally available like
great guy all this stuff but he's just
like emotionally available because
that's good that's what women want
y'all don't okay
you guys doing this yo one guy is
emotionally available what the [ __ ]
you know when the guys talk about when
they talk about sims yeah like a simp is
a guy that is emotionally available bro
but girls are won that [ __ ] they're
saying they want that [ __ ]
i'm telling you the truth but okay so he
has whatever i look for okay
continue
he has what you look for but he
continued
he's a little too emotionally available
he cries a lot i got it
like like privately you know when you're
like how much is something together how
much is it i'm talking about you like
like how about how hot
coming out his nose how often it's a
week once a month
honestly with this guy you know you
never know
give me the guy trying to [ __ ]
over there
okay guys um i appreciate the super
chats today um why don't you tell the
people where they can find you
um
once again my name is wolf you can find
me at uh on instagram only
at hay
dot
wolfy
that's w-o-l-f
e-y-y
[Applause]
it's been real
scary
you can find me
[Music]
blue therapy
b-l-u-u
therapy
and also you can find me at um open
courts
with zed open course we run into
scrimmages if anyone knows that it is if
you know what it is then just follow if
you don't follow it
um
you could also find me at the doghouse
three
doghouse you're not gonna remember that
their links are in the description
anyway
i i have people say it anyway yeah
my personal instagram i already shouted
out that's just oh really yeah i'll just
shout out everything to do a business
okay i'll put that one next time the
other one but thanks again for having me
yeah thanks thanks for coming you guys
will have to come back
i've been back
you may as well be a regular at this
point
okay guys um you already know if you
have watched two or more more of my live